côté il ya dans la manière dont le
gouvernement déroule son argumentaire
ces éléments de langage sur la
présomption d'innocence
un angle mort d'abord la présomption
d'innocence n'est nullement mis en cause
puisque monsieur darmanin du moins ses
avocats reconnaissent les faits les
fesses sont un échange de services
sexuelle une relation sexuelle contre
une promesse de passe-droits et le
premier ministre parle de présomption
d'innocence mais personne ne dit qu'il
est coupable
l'effet suffisent aujourd'hui pour qu'on
ait un point de vue sur ce qu'il a fait
que pense le premier ministre de cet
échange relations sexuelles contre passe
droit on ne sait toujours pas et je
pense que c'est une triple faute est une
faute à la fois politique éthique et
déontologique je rappelle que l'enquêté
toujours en cours sur les agissements de
monsieur darmana comment les policiers
vont ils pouvoir enquêter sur leur
ministre de tutelle
et pourtant à chaque décision de justice
gérald darmanin étaient déclarés
innocents alors il ya eu des décisions
de justice
effectivement épiler eu la réouverture
de l'anc est et pas simplement pour un
vice de procédure la réouverture de
l'enquêté l'étau studio fait qu'en
réalité il n'ya pas eu d' enquête
il n'a pas eu de confrontation avec la
victime et la cour d'appel a considéré
que l'enquêté était insuffisante pour
clore la sphère donc aujourd'hui il est
effectivement toujours présumé innocent
mais il est suspect et il est ministre
de l'intérieur ministre de tutelle des
enquêteurs on a donc là un véritable
poème d'anthologie qu indépendamment du
terrible message qui est envoyé aux
femmes qui elles vont déposer plainte
vont parle et on leur dit en fin de
compte c'est pas si grave ce qu'a fait
l'homme que vous dénoncez puisqu'il y en
a il peut être ministre de l'intérieur
ait changé relations sexuelles contre un
passe droit
donc pour vous charles de dharmanand
n'ai pas jeté en pâture à cause de cette
affaire
ah non il n'est pas jeté en pâture il
est aujourd'hui pas à sa place là où il
est comme ministre de l'intérieur et de
la part du président macron qui l'a
nommé à cet endroit en connaissant tous
les faits il y à la fois comme une
espèce d'indifférence sur les faits il
ya toujours aussi la mise en cause de la
plaignante comme dans toutes les
affaires de violences sexuelles on
cherche dans le passé de la plaignante
et puis il ya aussi cette faute
déontologique qui va rendre l'enfant
probablement plus compliquée pour les
enquêteurs pour terminer le premier
ministre jean castex a évoqué le fait
que gérald darmanin n'avait toujours pas
été mises en examen
est-ce que la mise en examen devient une
limite dans les propos du prix jusqu'à
présent on a vu eux des ministres qui
étaient très rapidement gouvernement
alors qu'ils n'étaient pas mises en
examen je pense à françois bayrou
marielle de sarnez sylvie goulard je
pense même à françois de rugy qui a
quitté le gouvernement pour avoir servi
du homard lorsqu'il était président de
l'assemblée il n'y avait même pas
d'infraction pénale en cause
et subitement il ya un changement de
jurisprudence du gouvernement et je suis
quand même étonné et choqué que ce
changement de jurisprudence se fasse
justement sur une violence sexuelle
merci beaucoup laurence rossignol pour
votre réaction